no man's sky has certainly received
heavy criticism since launch but if you
want to discuss the game's finer points
you might want to go somewhere other
than reddit the no man's sky subreddit
was briefly closed down with all content
purged it's possible to use an internet
archive to view older discussion threads
but for a time the only thing left was a
single message for moderator rogue wolf
which stated so i purged the subreddit
it's become a hate-filled waste whole of
no actual discussion it's not what we
intended it to be and I don't like
providing a platform for hate I'm sorry
to everyone who used the subreddit as
intended but you are now in the majority
I'm sure you can find a different place
to discuss this game it's not hard it
should be noted that the no man's sky
subreddit was not affiliated with
developer hello games as of the time of
this writing another mod by the handles
spork aside is working to reopen the
subreddit with a focus on more positive
discussion we'll keep you posted on that
and for all the biggest video game news
you're already in the right place